hello guys welcome to the stream
uh today's lecture on uh
outside the week in the moment uh this
is grandmaster's choice i decided to
pick something that i find personally
very interesting
and this is um
i'm going to talk about king's initial
defense namely them information
earlier during i think on sunday
i did the stream on twitch about
king's indian ideas in king's indian and
i was based
on kasparov's games game from 1978 i
believe
or seven don't know sure but uh
the games were basically the main line
of king's indian that
i just was kingsman the main end game
the main
position from the kings indian the main
line
today i'm gonna talk about a little bit
different system and i'm gonna talk
about
different let's say approach the system
which is quite modern and there have
been
very little games but i had the occasion
to play this system myself
so let's uh so i'll try to analyze it
and try to
show what's happening there so
um d4 knight f6 c4 g6
knight c3 bishop g7 e4 g6
a free short castle knight g2 and this
is amish system
of them very popular openings and
approaches to
king's indian i played myself as a long
time ago as a kid
like recently i haven't been playing it
lately i've been choosing
different systems neither three bishop
v2 them going for the main line
but the 392 is also very very good um
there also moves like we should be in
bishop g5 however here i would like to
solely focus on knight g2
and because after knight g2 there is one
modern basically line
right now for black that has been played
quite quite often but it's still
relatively new so this line is a6
and the idea of a6
i mean first of all many uh what black
can play here c5 transforming to
transforming the pawn structure after d5
to benoni from king's indian
second thing is possible with e5
obviously typical kingzina stuff
there are ideas of knight c6 and a6
let's say bishop e3 and a6 also is
possible
and finally there are also others but i
like personally a6
and this can be has been the recent
trend so i will just talk about this one
only and the idea of a6 is as many
people may suppose uh
is not a knight c6 to go back to let's
say the main line of knight
a6 or b8 which i just showed earlier
um but the idea is a little bit
different idea is after bishop e3 let's
say
there are also other moves but after
bishop e3 we go b5 we sacrifice the pawn
we but we open the we challenge the
center we change the c4 pawn we
sacrifice the
pawn ourselves and we try to quickly
develop some initiative and compensation
for
uh for respawn so uh this is the main
idea here
i see a6 with idea to play b5
same thing happens after move bishop g5
and to be honest doesn't it doesn't make
much difference i think bishop e3 is a
little bit better place because controls
better the center bishop g5 doesn't do
much so
again black can play b5 and we would
achieve the similar positions
uh so i'm not going to talk about this
because just improved version for black
uh and if knight g3 major free however
is
very good alternative because ig3 is
sort of
anticipating b5 uh right now b5 would be
pretty much stupid because after cb
a b bishop takes b5 white would be
while we have just extra upon and
normally the idea is
as we will see in the main line let's
say bishop e3 b5 takes takes knight b5
c6 we are chasing either way either way
and we are quickly
developing let's say sort of uh some
play in the center or on the queen side
and taking advantage of the white king
is still only one
in if knight g3 such approach is not
possible
because p5 as i said just ends up on
down
without any real compensation here so
here why black can play with h5 so the
idea of h5
is right now to change the size from g3
and i think this is a good approach here
as uh as black for instance
i consider two moves here for white uh
bishop d3 which is very logical
trying to you know if h4 then simply go
back with the knight to e2
in many instances or bishop g5 stopping
uh g4 stopping h4 altogether
so after bishop g5 i think the black
should play knight c6
and the problem is that knight on g3 is
not really uh
well placed right now uh considering
that pawn on d4
is not really depending upon the uh d4
so the idea could be the same knight h7
or something like this
queen d2 for instance knight h7 as i
said bishop e3
and the black can play for instance
bishop d7 there is there
also other moves but uh this is one of
one of possible
also possible will be e5 however we
don't have to rush with it but because
it's not clear how wide it will develop
bishop d3 is not possible
and the point is why not e5 that after
e5 would d5 knight d4
black white would have moved 99 to e2
challenging design on d4
and this is what black
doesn't really want that's why we'll
play bishop d7
and the idea of that after bishop b2 we
can then play e5 and d5 and then have
the first knight on d4 which can be
easily challenged with 92 and very
quickly with 92
okay so um
this is the kind of main idea and after
d5 we can play 95 and
uh not clear it's not clear what white
does next because f4 is always made by
them by knight g4
and if let's say bishop e2 we can play
we can begin continue uh
challenging the queens of b5 so here is
again why a6 is useful and
why a6 had been played a few moves
earlier hello guys
hello uh i cannot pronounce that hello
leon speaks
um sphinx so yeah b5 uh
is very uh strong right now and this is
kind of like typical
in sort of bangko style bank of gambit
style
position we can always consider playing
h4 h3 there are lots of
uh possibilities to play here uh
you know as black
so this knight so this is what happened
after the bishop g5
let's see what happens after bishop d3
because this seems to be more natural
where the developing piece
especially after h4 can simply go back
92 and then castle
castle the king side hello chess king
uh hello gg rr all right
so now h4 is possible obviously but we
can start with c5
and uh ace again we may you may
someone may ask why a6 why do we need a6
to play c5
and my answer to is that anytime
d5 happens we have or as we have already
pawn b5 upon a6 we can quickly go b5
and open the send open the queen side
and the play benko style
after let's say d5 we can play already
for instance b5
and this is the let's say idea
right now why why it is why a6 was
placed a played we can always play
through b5 and challenge this ball on c4
for instance in such uh you know version
of
benoni slash banker so for instance
analyze xb5
and after acetax b5 there are many moves
uh possible there is not bd7 possible
there is h4 to start with but i thought
this e6
again challenging the sender from this
side is would be very nice
and after casual i think that it takes
d5
it takes d5 h4 chasing this knight away
knight take 94 i mean 92 will be very
positive h1 be even more passive so 94
makes a lot of sense
knight takes e4 and right now uh i think
that black white has to stay with the
pawn on e4
um and i don't if if knight takes e4
there could be ideas of some uh you know
8xb5 and then maybe some queen b6 and
the bishop has
will be chased away and if bishop takes
e4
bishop is also misplaced there let's say
a b knight b5 bishop a6 will be possible
so i thought f takes e4 is sort of must
to keep let's say
sort of balance on b5 square but after
queen b6 king h1 for instance this did
an id7
this right now black knight lands lens
on e5
and even though white has extra upon i
think black has
great compensation for respawn and in
general uh
if you ask me who would like to play
this position
with more i would definitely choose
black here
[Music]
hey steve great i'm happy i'm happy
that they helped um all right
so knight d7 and 95 comes in bishop a6
is great position for black definitely
still complicated
phone down but definitely a great
conversation here as black so this
knight g3 is quite
kind of easily you know dealt with by
this approach
but in this approach of h5 so let's see
what happens after bishop e3 and b5
bishop e3 b5 and
it's it seems like white is just winning
the pawn right now
c take b5 a takes b5 and knight takes b5
right
so uh right now i think um
[Music]
at first when i saw this line first time
ever i saw design photos just kind of
like a joke
uh that's to give this pawn like this
and
then i start analyzing and i realize
that things are far from easy and far
from clear
what's the main sort of advantage of you
know sacrificing this pawn
is that white's control over the center
is not
as strong as with this pawn on c4 and
this
possib this gives a
possibility to sort of change
the center and fight for the you know
initiative in the center very quickly
and much much more efficiently than with
disposal c4
the topic of today's lesson is king's
indian defense damage
system and from black's perspective i'm
talking about the variation
with here i'll just move back few moves
uh
knight g2 and here a6 this is the line
i'm talking about
and this is kind of modern new modern
line so um
this is my this is the topic for today
uh
bishop e3 as i said b5 it's take b5 it
takes b5 and takes b5
and here black should play c6
and white has two moves two
possibilities two knight bc3 and knight
a3 knight a3 personally doesn't look
personally to me it doesn't look good at
all like so just nicely goes to the edge
of the board
and simply seemingly for no reason uh
it's not so bad though the idea is that
may sometimes
uh this knight uh from it okay we may go
to c3 and knight from a3 will go maybe
to c4 or something like this
still uh i think that afternoon knight a
sorry not a free black has you know very
good dynamic play after c5
angela king's indian is very dynamic
opening
uh you cannot sort of like you know be
happy
playing this with black when uh you
can't be happy
when you when you play this opening and
you play let's say
passive or not active chess you have to
play very dynamic
uh very aggressive chess because
otherwise you may just
uh end up like right now upon down
imagine
playing this position moves like column
moves like i don't know maybe
bishop a6 maybe just 97 not queen c7
rook b8
while simply different pawns and pawn b2
develop the king side and we'll just
retain extra pawn
so this is not the the way you play
king's indian you have to play very
dynamic chess
and here black challenges the center of
c5 immediately
taking advantage of this knight on a3
which is misplaced and here analyzed
several
possibilities for for white main one
being detached c5 capturing the second
pawn
so uh after let's say queen d2 i think
blah blah can just play knight c6 and
after d5 knight before
knight on b4 is pretty good uh bishop a6
can be played not next or
mostly most importantly move like e6
changing the center again
uh we got some benko like uh
position and this uh i think it's just
simply great for black
[Music]
so hello nikolai uh so um
after knight c6 yeah so the queen d2 i
thought this simply not so
so great uh knight b5 also is
possibility but like what's the point of
playing knight d3 knight b5
back and forth right so it doesn't make
much sense
right now black can play for instance c
takes d4 knight takes d4 and play
quickly e5 and after 93 played d5
opening the center challenging you know
whites
actually win controversy center and
possibly
maybe playing d4 in the future if not
not taking if it's not taking on
uh d5 also on the possibility to take on
let's say bishop d3 is possible to take
on e4 and challenge somehow this pawn on
e4 in those lines for instance i played
something like this knight bishop c4 z9
queen e7
short castle and the raiden attacks
before could be possible
it is a very unclear position still
obviously however
uh i feel like black you know would be
doing generally great here
so white generally should take on c5 but
again c5 may
have can be met by queen a5 uh
can you play king's indian uh
against my op any opening like in
english or london
you can play it against london
against english yeah but the thing is
that white doesn't have to play then d4
and so on so white can sort of play
let's say different setups but you can
definitely play
almost anything i think actually on
anything after let's say d4 and c4 and
knight f3 you can play
almost on any thing just you know kings
and kings indian setup with knight f6 g6
bishop g7
showcasing d6 so it's very flexible
but white doesn't have to play move like
c you know d4
for instance if you play english c4
let's say i'm at f6 and c3 g6
you can you don't have to play let's say
e4 but you can play maybe g3 or
something and then just play without d4
so this uh is this will be a little bit
different
coming back to this uh line queen a5
here there are two moves queen d2 or
bishop d2 after queen d2 i think black
is simply
uh nearly better after queen takes d2
queensland's two and now there is knight
xe4 possible
so therefore um what i'm trying to say
is that
black has very good dynamic
opportunities in this uh
opening after af takes e4 bishop takes
b2 knight c2
takes on a1 new knight xa1 rook takes a2
knights c2 and finally takes c5 and
because of white king that is
so exposed despite the queen the queen's
being
of the board and lack of development on
the of the
of white pieces i don't think uh that
wore black is in any danger here
if anything black could be only i think
maybe slightly better potentially some
chances
also there are two pawns for the two
pawns and the rook for two minor pieces
so let's say i i mean i don't really
think that black
takes any serious risk here
potentially black could be even better
so
queen d2 is not really good bishop d2
queen takes c5 rook c1 um
is logical too but we can play just
queen a7 and
just look at this king like king only
one is not easily gonna be
you know put safety on the king side
with us with with castle first of all
the screen on this diagonal
covers all you know all the possible all
the squares
and pawn on the f3 doesn't help as well
right so
i think that black has really good
compensation here even though
you know white has extra pawn and uh
again i would prefer probably playing
this with with black here
uh i didn't i'd analyze a little bit
further but i think
here is already kind of clear that black
the
box positions is good
so uh we can ignore 93 and we can stick
with knight bc3
and after knight bc3 black should play
knight bd7
and someone may ask okay we played we
just gave the pawn and
then we just developed the pieces named
d7 and so what
uh then i just say that
hold on just king didn't i just say that
you know if black
plays uh uh
you know slowly like with 997 and so on
black will
be just pawn down i did but like
knight b7 is a move that really prepares
action in the center right now that's
after queen d2
uh we don't go bishop a6 queen seven
rugby a because it would be too slow
true but we go for something else and
we'll show ourselves in a moment
uh all those variations looks like black
is easier to play they don't do anything
wrong
black is easier to play true um
why didn't but we so far analyze not the
best reactions from
from what's perspective right now we are
going back to the main line with knight
b c3
so this is basically main knight bd7 and
here
you know sort of you know the main fight
happens but i just want to discuss first
sidelines
to see that you know running away from
this line is may not be actually
really efficient everywhere black is
doing well and black is kind of easy
play
so knight bd7 and here there uh
i analyze mostly tools queen d2 which is
typical moving all kind of zemis
structures or move knight c1
knight idea of knight c1 is to play
bishop e2 short castle
and played and keep designed let's say
on the queens of knight b3
so uh let's discuss both of them let's
start with knight c1
and afternoon c1 uh essentially black
plays both
same thing after both queen d2 and
knight c1 black has to play right now e5
and the point is that without pawn on c4
after trading this pawn from c4
right now we want to play simply d5 we
are immediately fighting for the center
and we considering the white king is
still
you know not cut this is still in castle
still needs some time to castle we have
time to develop the devil some
unbalance in the center uh some
unbalanced tension in the center
which can give us advantage dynamically
for instance after bishop e2
we can play d5 as i said and
right now there is white has some choice
obviously
and here i would like to actually show
one of my games i mean i played in this
line as black only one game
against circa
salic i think it's his name so uh
it was on in july this year i believe
so uh in the game up and it takes e5
alternatives involve moves like
rook uh shortcast or knight b3 but both
of them lead to similar positions so i'm
just gonna skip them
and i focus only what happened in this
game detects e5 knight takes e5
short castle and now i play d takes e4
idea is after quintex d8 rook takes d8
pawn takes e4
we can see that knight on e5 my knight
on e5 is very
uh strong bishop on g7 on the diagonal
also
uh is well placed to
cover you know put some pressure
potentially on on b2 pawn
and the fact that we have the black has
black doesn't have a pawn on a queen on
the queen side is pretty much
nearly irrelevant because we have we can
use b file to attack the b two bond and
bishop from j7 attacked on this diagonal
and while cannot really use the
disadvantage of that
of the extra pawn so i played knight
knight to knight
g4 as as you guys can see i play very
dynamically
right now i i do not want to
waste time for any uh let's say because
first of all bishop g5 could be
sort of a threat this could be so i have
to take this one out
let this arrow out bishop could be sort
of a threat so if i play with like
bishop e6 which is of course very
natural but
then why would let's say put play maybe
bishop g5 and i sort of have to go back
over 97 or maybe
sacrifice an exchange not something i
really like
that's why knight eg4 i instead of
just you know making random bishop move
i
start attacking so bishop g5
and i saw this pin with h6
we should take g4 if bishop
you know would go to to h4 i can at
least play
g5 if i want to probably just g5 is
is good like and then you know after
this i can have many moves
uh one of the let's say good moves would
be to play move knight e3
other would be rook d2 i have a number
of ideas here
in in my hand that i can use i really
like 93 personally
so uh this would be not good therefore
uh white had to take on g4 i take on g5
or
bishop takes you in the rook they see
rook takes c8 but it was also okay to
tell this one this work however i want
to control the default
uh probably doesn't quite matter
uh maybe maybe still rook dc video
dba will be a little more accurate but
this is also okay
so uh we got this position and this is
already
i know this is kind of like middle games
logic maybe end game
but it as it stems from the results from
this opening
uh this line with a6 i really want to go
to make a few more moves just to show
what kind of
ideas here are for black uh knight b3
knight g4 uh rook ad1 and and right now
i still playing on d3
take stakes rook e1
and knight c4 i use my bishop on g7 to
attack those pawns
it's obvious that why do not have any
advantage
and black has great initiative or at
least great compensation
for respawn black is simply not worse
for sure
the game happened rookie 2 and i played
g4 just to sort of create
some maybe potential weaknesses on the
king side
um king f2 bishop e5
g3 you guys can see that right now on
pawn g4
is uh making pawn h2 a potential
weakness
also i i have access to a free square so
i might consider moves like rook f3 in
the future
i didn't do it yet i at first play king
g7
and in the here actually i would like to
maybe stop
talking about this game because the game
was like 42 moves and
there's no it's not already a topic uh
you know about this opening
in general what i'm trying to say is
that black has
always some compensation for this pawn
and this
then white has to be very careful to
defend it in this game i managed to win
however you know my opponent made some
mistakes
uh but still those mistakes result from
that it's
from the fact that it's very easy to
play for black well why has to be
extremely careful
and it may some of some decisions or
choices may not be obvious during the
during the game
so i think you know here black is just
doing great
so this is what happens after moon
knight c1 right
trying to play quickly bishop e2 and
shore castle then one play e5 and d5
with good
good play after queen d2 it appears that
black also plays e5 end with idea of d5
and because this pawn is not c4 we can
we can simply change the center like
that
and right now knight g3 is the main move
and knight g3 is the main move and after
knight g3
there are uh several apartment ninja
feet there are several options here for
white
first of all let's discuss what happens
after bishop h6
do you guys what would and we are
watching what would you
play
because seemingly logical betray those
bishops right
so i'm like if you guys can say in chat
what would you play here
with black
do not take what do you mean steve
probably bishop a6 uh no
bishop a6 bishop h8 is actually typical
idea of course
uh but it is not good great in this
particular moment
uh rook e1 i'm not sure what is okay
queen seven
no none of those moves are you know
i mean all they are possible but they're
by far not the best try to find the best
move
queen h6 what are you what do you mean
steve i'm confused
knight b6 is also another move dc
dc you can play dc here
maybe you meant d5 uh d5 is possible i
guess
but it's not great c5 is also
sorry knight b6 is also not great c5
also i don't
really like
[Music]
the bishop takes queen takes on h6 yes
yes yes we don't like this visualization
queen likes h6 happens yes
i mean i'm saying basic is the move but
uh okay
just to because there is still something
to some you know sometimes i would like
to show you
so uh instead of uh you right now trying
to find it i'll just show you the
solution because there are still
you know lots of uh interesting stuff
going on in this line
so uh in this position
black can play knight x e4
probably in on like at least you were
not saying in chat about this
uh so i guess that you didn't see it
but the idea is of course right now to
remove the knight from
uh f6 and right now the idea is to play
queen h4 and
there is a double attack on h6 and on
check on e1
yes so uh knight takes e4
simply actually is very strong
i'm not saying that black is much better
here because probably after
knight takes queen h4 g3 queen takes h6
let's say take take knight d6 white is
still holding
white is still holding i guess but the
pair of bishops
much better development open position
definitely favors black here
uh so uh by black and played move like
bishop a6 or something just bring
you know all the pieces to the game and
i think that black uh
only black can be better here so this is
one of the typical ideas actually in
king's indian
whenever this point is on a free in
zamish it happens quite often
um so that's why i'm bringing it up
because it's a typical king's
idea here so um
so yeah so another another another
possibility for why
here is to play with d5 and after d5 uh
i i'm i think that really uh what
i mean d5 also makes sense like extra
pawn right for white and try to
block sorry lock the center keep it
position closed
which makes sense however
right now we can again change the center
of this knight b6
and in all those lines this missing pawn
on the queen side doesn't quite matter
what's most important is the
active fight going on in the center and
let's say detect c6 i was analyzing
knight c4
if queen c1 we can just take take and
sip the bishop e6
and right now we got the pair of bishops
uh
we can play we can the even though the
pawn on c6 it seems like it's kind of
strong
we we can basically quickly uh recapture
it very likely we will recapture it with
move like queen seven or maybe queen a5
rook c8 rook c6
and what's the most important right now
again white black's idea is to play d5
at some point
open the center play against white's
king who still is in the center
still isn't a center of this king and
black uh sorry white doesn't have any
more dark square bishop which is uh
definitely also a problem here
because without our queer bishop all you
know let's say if the position opens
this bishop white black bishop on g7 can
become powerful
really really powerful
so i think black has great compensation
here for missing two pawns
so yeah here another move that i was
considering here is rook d1
and after rook d1 uh of course
right now we go with d5
and the point is that after it takes d5
because robot one seemingly is normal
natural right rook d idea of rock do you
want is to
you know sort of like kind of like
take more control over the center and
like you know be ready
for any action going in the center uh of
course long castle could be possible but
like
personally i find this move nearly
suicidal because going for long castle
in such position
open everywhere everything is open and
on the on the queen side
it's really really dangerous and risky
so i don't i wouldn't consider this move
uh
as really you know good for a while
first of all something can happen and d5
and
you know sender opens queenside open is
already opened and killed c1 will be
very exposed
king belongs to the king side here so
long castle is not really a thing
instead rogue d1 sort of also tries to
prepare for
you know action in the center after rook
d1 black can play move d5
yeah and after d5 it takes d5 knight
takes d5 knight takes d5 c takes d5
so here again black has x white has
extra pawn
but black king but white king is in the
center and um
[Music]
i think that black has again more than
sufficient compensation here
so uh dwight has in general i would say
two candidate moves one move is uh
knight c3 just try to you know
bring this finally bishop from f1 to e2
and then castle short side and
finish development try to prove the
that the pawn extra pawn is that will
matter or
the second approach is to take on e5 and
maybe
put some pressure on this d5 pawn
immediately
so hello peter
so let's let's look at both of them uh
if
d takes e5
knight takes e5 knight c3 let's say
uh of course if queen takes d5 we can we
could
always take on a2 if we want to let's
say take on d5 take on a2 also that move
like knight c4 there is more than
sufficient compensation
also we can keep queens on the board
which i think is even the strongest
or maybe not it's possible
black is fine in either way man icy
freeholder makes more sense because it
brings the
knight to the game finally at that one
stage with the knight on d5
d4 is not possible yet and wants to play
bishop e2 and short castle obviously
but right now there are certain issues
that black uh the white runs into
uh rook e8
king f2 and now queen h4
we basically chased this king away the
problem is that
bishop e2 may run into let's say some
unpleasant uh
tactics i'm not exactly sure right now
uh what kind of tactics but i guess that
there should be something on the e-file
like for instance involving maybe
bishop a6 sometimes even or
maybe some jasmine queen h4 uh
i know king of two ionized bishop e2 by
somebody i i didn't analyze
however it's pretty pretty logical and
natural move
maybe knight c4 my c4 could be possible
actually you have to
quiz visually for queen h4 this is kind
of like look thinking about it right now
and this could be actually really good
for black because of the spin this rook
bishop cannot hide
and queen uh f2 rook takes e3
the queen of if queen f2 rook takes e3
simply wins right
so the king will have to go there but
then we can take the queen
on c4 and we have still uh
very strong initiative here as black so
i think this would be really good knight
c4 bishop c4 and
queen h4 so uh
king f2 and trying to prepare at least
there we know any
uh you know persian they fought king if
he's preparing on this line
then black play can play queen h4 g3 and
rhino queen f6
and there is certain pressure on a free
square right now
bishop f4 logical because if bishop g2
knight c4
again wins if n or
knight g4 after let's say knight bishop
e2 knight g4 will win just put it on the
board
bishop c4 both knight g4 knight c4 wins
let's see let's sign on g4
and bishop e2 also known as g4 wins
right so
um because the the of the pin on the f5
and the black wins that bishop on e3 so
bishop before has to be played
and right now uh can you spot the idea
here for what would you play here as
black
again this opening is very dynamic so
you need to
just develop the initiative
how would you continue
g5 i think after g5 i'll play knight xd5
and it takes d5 i'm not taking on g5 g5
knight x5 attack your queen
no g4 does the g5 doesn't force we
should have z5
after g5 i'm gonna play knight takes d5
right
maybe repetitive but like you guys are
keep saying gg5 in chat so i just want
to
make sure knight g4
uh d4 suggestion if knight g4
i'll just take it i guess and then see
okay then you can play g5 but still i've
just played knight xd5 and i think i
went here
uh queen b6 is possible too uh
d4 also is possible if d4 i'll probably
play
just knight e4 and i'll try to sort of
hold it together
uh queen b6 after queen b6 i'll probably
just play bishop e3
and try to sort of also hold it together
but knight takes f3 finally yes
knight takes f3 is the solution
basically just opening everything
bishop opening uh attacking the king
opening it
as quickly as possible if king takes a
free
black can play right now d4 which would
be much stronger or bishop b7 first
uh both i think i think d4 immediately
will be even stronger
so after king takes the three d4 for
instance would just be
crashing i think because this diagonal
is open bishop comes to b7
next move
so it looks really powerful and after
but so black white cannot take the
knight but after uh there is move
knight takes d5 so as a kunai xd5 there
is move queen e6
and after king takes f3 how would you
continue here
bishop b7 is a it's possible but um
okay any other suggestion previous on
spock is possible but it's
i'll play uh probably
i'll be probably sorry
probably i'll be able to kind of like
hold it here however uh
queen 4 is also like logical but in my
opinion
the by by far the best because just just
kind of like from theoretical
perspective
bishop on c8 is not a bad piece can
support someone maybe queen g4 maybe
queen for bishop g4 or something like
this right
but we can just collect this pawn and
look if ever this king goes to f2 or
something we can play group takes b2
and we we pin on the second rank
and i think that after rook takes a2
basically preparing everything because
bishop besides an idea
queen e4 is an idea but rookie on a2
improves also the rook and prepares
taking on b2
chasing this queen away and further
attacking black white king
and i think after root is a2 the game is
nearly over
because this king is so weak and i think
that black
has overwhelming initiative and
i don't see how white would be able to
defend
defense here
it's hard to actually come with the move
here for for white because
everything is met with something
uh so i think that's pretty much game
over right now
but all your ideas are valid that we are
suggesting we should be 7 24 and so on
the thing is we can start with rook a2
and keep all our ideas and suddenly what
has
pretty much no moves and then we can
employ those ideas
with even more strength so
yeah this is basically it uh suddenly
black develops such a quick initiative
in the center
uh so
okay let me let me answer that uh
queen g3 queen f6 should be four
uh what if queen e4 and rook takes
okay okay no choice king f2 you take
okay uh right now i have first of all
bishop g2
yes it wins but like i'm gonna win your
queen for instance there is a rook h1
for instance
and just imagine having already europe
on a2
you will be able to let's say always
play rook takes b2 right so all those
lines
would be uh
yes white is much better here here white
is much better so therefore i'm not
playing queen e4
but instead here of queen e4 uh rook
takes a
two right because after queen e4
queen h1 bishop g2 white is much better
yes here white is much better as
maurices are points out
so yeah um all right let's move to the
next line
because this is a perfectly example of
like what happens
uh when uh when white simply you know
tries to capture the opponent try to
prevent let's say black center play but
and anyway the sensor play happens and
suddenly white king is remains in the
center and
is being gained nearly checkmated number
20.
so uh better in my opinion would be
knight c3
but knight c3 here we can play just rook
e8
and king f2 and this is a little bit
better approach here by white
because at least black knight is still
on d7 not only five right
so it's very this is very similar but
black black knight is not as active
here however you can play e4 and here in
such position bishop b2 let's say queen
h4 king given analyze and bishop a6 for
instance
and here i think black in general has
very good compensation
here i think that black has in general
very very good compensation
uh for the pawn uh especially the king
on g1
is uh simply you know not gonna castle
uh
he's not gonna so isn't ken castle is
you know
is weak and potent potentially black can
uh develop some issues against this king
right
so this is better for white than than
you know previous line where black is
winning with this rook a2 line
uh however still i don't think uh the
black has any problems here i think
black is doing great and
potentially can even be better here uh
one thing for sure it's definitely way
easier to play this position as black
because of simple development and
activity rather than with white
uh with king on g1 and rugged h1 that
are completely misplaced right
so um
so yeah so therefore rook d1 also is not
a great idea here for white
so finally knight g3 i was thinking
could be
could be played here knight g3
and trying to sort of strengthen the
center on e4
consider anticipating also d5 because
right now for knight from g3 will be
supporting e4 square better but
knight from uh g3 it's all nine g4
also uh not doesn't have bright future
in terms of you know it doesn't really
go to f5 or h5 or anywhere it just does
kind of like defensive tasks
uh so sorry it also has some
drawbacks it's a good move but you know
not without drawbacks
so knight g after knight g3 and here i
think black has two approaches possible
i really like the
d5 again d5 is in my opinion by far
uh what the best choice here for black
alternative would be it takes d4 after
bishop takes d4 knight c5
and again we just play for initiative
bring it knight to e6 and
again try to play with d5 bishop v3 and
d5 for instance
of course move like bishop f6 queen f6
which is in queen d6 would be too
dangerous
to give you with such powerful bishop on
g7 uh black always will have great
compensation
rook d8 is possible uh on a move like
queen h4r quiz is possible there are
many possibilities here for black
and i think that black is doing simply
great here
and most importantly what king is still
in the center only one
so it cannot be good for for white
so bishop e3 and then d5
and similar stuff happens and probably
here white can
maintain equality by simply taking
everything
and uh here black doesn't have anything
better than this this rook a2 and
capture on b2
and such equal position but you know
you know sometimes equal positions
happen right but on the other hand
even if they happen uh as black we
shouldn't be too worried about
because as black we always have to first
equalize
and then play for uh kind of like then
try to improve our advantage
or like prove some advantage so that to
you know we
our that we have good chances to win uh
doesn't mean they have to we we can't
play for a draws in move number one i'm
not talking about this but first
step is to equalize and then after
equalizing play for a win
uh because it's unlikely that uh
or may i mean of course can happen but
like you know
you know one the player with white will
make with correct play
suddenly uh that there will be a
possibility to play for a win
from like very quickly from the
beginning of the game unless of course
the blunders happen
then of course it's possible right but
we are assuming right now perfect play
from
from white as well with perfect play
from white
we cannot expect to be better as well as
black after the opening as i'm trying to
say
so this is one possibility here and
second possibility after knight g3 is to
play simply again d5 and i it probably i
would just stick with d5 because just so
natural
uh to play d5 and uh
yeah like for instance if bishop b2
black can play just h5 this idea of
knight on g3 idea of h5 is very typical
in all sorts of kings indian positions
especially in in this
zamish variation in in king's indian
after it takes e5 knight xe5 bishop b2
again h5
so we could basically transpose from the
from the previous previous line
short castle and right now h4
h9h1 so finally let's look at this
position
white castle but white
is actually sorry black is actually
controlling the center
better than white knight on e5 pawn on
d5
white has pawn on knight sorry knight on
h1 which is very passive uh
despite the fact that uh white already
castle there is still possibility for
uh for black to develop some initiative
against white king with move like h3 for
instance
so this king it doesn't is not still
completely safe the white black still
has some initiative
that can you know pose lots of practical
problems
i'm not saying black is better i'm not
saying at all black is better but
position is very complicated it's very
unclear
but if you are looking for a line that
offers very good chances and uh
to play for winners with black and who
induces some mistakes for everyone
because
just look guys how many mistakes uh we
already
uh black uh sure serial paper sure
sure people intro i will see you next
time um
just look how many mistakes one could
have made already in this game like
so much right uh and only with best play
like
bringing you know this funny knight to
h1 and
white you know manages to keep uh
keep equality so this
this just shows that the position is
extremely
complicated and it is not easy to play
with this position with white
so if you are looking for a line to play
for a win i would say in
damage variation considering i would
suggest 6a6 and then
play for b5 sacrifice upon and fight for
the center
and basically just whatever i'm talking
in here present right now h g6 sorry g2
king takes g2
uh bishop e6 and right now um i think
yeah pawn down true but
look at this perfect development of
pieces
and we king on g2 even though it's the
castle still is exposed
and i think it's simply black is doing
great here
uh so just to sum it up because
in another lecture my lecture is coming
and i think right now
um i fortunately have to stop talking
about i could talk longer
of course but i think we sort of
we are running out of time on this uh
grandmaster's choice
uh just to sum it up i think that this
line in king's indian
uh zamasu variation a6 just to bring it
up in the
end uh this position knight g2 and a6
i think it's a very interesting uh and
sharp line which gives
black good chances to fight for the ford
initiative not saying that this is
better for black
for sure is not better but it definitely
gives
white some food for thought and i think
that um
the chance that white makes but what
what is white player with white makes a
mistake here
not being ready for this line is quite
substantial so it will surprise your
opponent
and get good uh great i mean get a great
fighting and attacking position with
also dynamics
play a play 6a6 here so
that's all from me for now again about
king's indian and i will be back
very soon with uh next
next lesson which will be games of the
week
so stay tuned and i'll see you soon
tracy do i uh
once again